à tous les artisans tous les commerçants
de l'essonne un grand merci bonjour à
tous françois durovray président du
département de l'essonne je suis heureux
de vous accueillir chez moi avec un
petit caméraman spécial puisqu'il s'agit
de mon dernier fils victor alors
évidemment comme un compliment ça a été
un grand changement parce que j'ai pour
habitude d'être en contact des équipes
du conseil départemental des ppte sur le
terrain aux côtés des essonniens aimé
puis à moi je m'applique comme n'importe
quel français
le confinement pour avoir le moins de
contacts possibles et appliqués les
gestes barrière je suis amené à aller
novembre régulièrement au bureau parce
que le département est en première ligne
sur la gestion de cette crise notamment
avec les maisons de retraite
pour moi la consommation n'a pas
vraiment changé parce que j'ai la chance
à montgeron d'avoir un grand et beau
marché ok auprès duquel j'ai pour
habitude de m'approvisionner et je
continue à le faire comme à voir c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment où on profite des
fraises françaises qui commencent à
arriver des asperges que j'adore et le
confinement ça me permet meute est aussi
de d'avoir un petit peu plus de temps
pour retrouver ma cuisine parce que
j'adore cuisiner ça fait partie des
bonnes choses qu'on a dans cette crise
concept aussi que nos concitoyens en
profite pour redécouvrir ce commerce de
proximité parce qu'ils vont davantage
chez leurs commerçants de bouche et
c'est une bonne chose et je voudrais
remercier tous les artisans qui sont
engagés sur ce défi de
l'approvisionnement de
nos concitoyens on a accès aux commerces
de bouche et c'est une très bonne chose
mais il ya d'autres artisans qui lui
manque
et à titre personnel lui comme tous les
français je pense y en a un qui me
manque beaucoup c'est mon coiffeur parce
que ça commence à devenir un peu
compliqué ans j'ai hâte de le revoir et
pire d'un autre aussi que gérant envie
de revoir c'est l'artisan qui avait fait
mon devis juste avant le confinement
pour réparer un véhicule qui est tombé
en panne dans la crise elle est là on
est en train de la gérer mais il faut
aussi penser à l'après crise en tant que
citoyen en tant que président du
département
je le fais pour qu' on puisse au maximum
tirer profit de ce qui se passe il pas
d'une façon générale nos concitoyens se
rendre compte qu'il faut faire davantage
attention à leurs achats à être
davantage dans le local dans la qualité
être un peu moins dans l'achat compulsif
je crois qu'on est seul on est un peu
mieux armé que notre territoire pour le
père parce qu'on a anticipé les grands
changements notamment sur la transition
énergétique au travers un paiement de la
prime écologique que nous avons créée il
ya un an et qui a donné un sacré coup de
booster à toutes les entreprises du
bâtiment
moi je ne peux qu'encourager tous les a
prises en tous les commerçants du
département à relever ce défi
par exemple en organisant des livraisons
des systèmes de livraison des des
commerces de bouche à l'échelle de
chacune des villes parce que certains de
nos concitoyens ont envie d'avoir des
produits de qualité mais n'ont pas
forcément le temps parce qu'il travaille
beaucoup pas y avoir une réorientation
des dépenses
après cette crise sans doute pour
privilégier davantage l'artisanat
un autre sujet que nous travaillons
depuis quelques mois avec les
agriculteurs pour fournir à lui
alimentation locale de qualité si
possible bio on essaie de le faire dans
les collèges
je suis convaincu que cette crise avait
donné l'occasion d'aller beaucoup plus
loin et de convertir l'ensemble des
essonniens
en fait cette crise ya évidemment du mal
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'opportunités
à saisir c'est peut-être le message en
temps présent département que je
voudrais vous transmettre en tout cas je
voudrais dire à tous les artisans tous
les commerçants de l'essonne un grand
merci d'être mobilisés pour
approvisionner au mieux les essonniens
[Musique]